فتاة لم أتركك تذهب أبدًا
[موسيقى] يسعدني
جيسوس
مقابلتك يا رفاق ومرحبًا بكم في أبو
ظبي
[موسيقى]
أممممم حتى الآن أعتقد أننا لا نعرف حقًا
مدى الاختلاف ، إنها المرة الأولى التي نقدم فيها عرضًا
هنا أه تعلمون في هذا
بلد وكنا نرغب دائمًا في المجيء إلى
هنا لأنه في تعليقاتنا
هناك الكثير من الورود السوداء أو المعجبين
الذين دائمًا ما يعلقون باللغة العربية
وأنت تعلم أنه على الرغم من أننا لا نستطيع قراءتها ،
يمكننا ترجمتها ومعرفة ما
يقولونه  سيقول دائمًا تعال ،
يرجى الأداء هنا ، وأخيراً نحن
نعلم هنا أه نحن سعداء جدًا لأننا
نستطيع الأداء هنا ، لكننا لم
نقم بالأداء حتى الآن ، لذا لا أعرف
الفرق الكبير حتى الآن ولكننا  نحن
متحمسون حقًا لمعرفة ما سيكون عليه الأمر ،
لذلك نحن متحمسون حقًا لأن نواصل مهاجمته
ولكن عارياً أو نفكر
واليراعات  آمل أن تتمكن من رؤيتنا في
أي مكان ونأمل أن نأتي إلى
هنا  ثم أقوم بحفل موسيقي خاص أيضًا ، وها
نحن مثلكم قال
لنا الحفلة الموسيقية الخاصة جولتنا الخاصة هي أداءنا الرئيسي
كما نفعل آه خاصة عندما
لا يكون هناك العديد من الفرق
الموسيقية مثل أفضل مثل مهرجانات Kpop
، من الصعب فعل ذلك  قم بإعداد إعداد الفرقة وإعداد
الطبول وجميع الآلات
ولكن أه كان مذهلاً لأننا
الفرقة الوحيدة لهذا المهرجان اليوم
وقمنا بإعداد جميع
معداتنا واستعدنا للقيام بمجموعة الفرقة الكاملة
الحية و  أنت تعلم أن جعل هذا الأمر
ممكنًا كان بمثابة جمال بالنسبة لنا ، شكرًا
جزيلاً لك وأه كما تعلم أعتقد أن
كل شيء يعود إلى 20 شخصًا
100 شخص 1000 شخص في
نهاية اليوم كان الأمر متشابهًا بالنسبة لنا
فقط نقوم بالأداء أمام
الأشخاص الذين يحبون موسيقانا ونتواصل
مع موسيقاها حتى تعرف أين
أشعر بأننا دائمًا نمتلك نفس الطاقة
ونتلقى نفس الطاقة من
حيث عدد الأشخاص الذين تعرفون مدى ضخامة
الجمهور  أو ما مدى صغرها ، هذا أمر
مثير للاهتمام حقًا  ظننتكم يا رفاق أن هذا يعني
أنه أكثر حميمية عندما تعلمون نعم ،
نعم بالتأكيد عندما يكون هناك ما يقرب من
20 شخصًا ، فمن الحميمية جدًا ،
لقد قمنا بعروض مع 20 شخصًا عندما
بدأنا لأول مرة ، قمنا بالعمل
مع 10 أشخاص فقط  الناس المارة
وقد قدمنا ​​عروضًا مع 2000
شخص ونقوم بالعرض الليلة
وماذا سيكون الأمر مثل 10000 شخص أو
شيء من هذا القبيل يمكن أن يكون أكثر نعم
ولكن في نهاية اليوم يبدو الأمر كما لو
أن الموسيقى هناك  ونحن جميعًا نتواصل من
خلال موسيقانا ، وكل ما علينا فعله
هو أن نكون الأشخاص الذين
يرسلونها ويصادف أن الأشخاص الموجودين هناك
هم الأشخاص الذين يستقبلونها ، لذلك
لدينا اتصال الطاقة هذا ،
لذا نعم بغض النظر عن السبب  يبدو الأمر
كبيرًا كما تعلمون لمجرد أنه مثل 20
شخصًا ، لا يبدو أنه صغير ، صحيح أنه
لا يزال يشعر بالرقص الكبير والحميمي
لمجموعات K-pop الراقصة ،
حسنًا ، 100 ضربة
ربما ليو ،
لذلك أريدهم فعلاً
أن يشاركوا في بعض.  أحداث من
هذا القبيل لأنني كنت  إنهم جميعًا
الحشود جميع المعجبين لدينا لمعرفة
مدى روعتهم ، أوه ،
ربما لا أعرف ، نعم من أجل المتعة ، أعتقد أنه
بمجرد أن تعجبك الحفلة الموسيقية الفردية الخاصة بك ، فقم
بتقديم عروض إضافية لأصدقائك الذين تعلمون
لدينا  لقد تلقيت الكثير من التعليقات من
هذا القبيل وأنت تعلم أننا نستطيع ولكن
لا
يمكننا فعلًا ذلك ، لكن لا ينبغي لنا
حقًا أن تعتقد أن هذا سيعطي
مظهرًا مختلفًا ، ما الذي تدور
حوله الوردة إذا لم تفعل ذلك  لا أعتقد ذلك
في نهاية اليوم مثل الوردة
بغض النظر عما نفعله بشكل صحيح ، لقد فعلنا
الكثير من الأشياء المضحكة التي كنا نفعلها كثيرًا ، لا
يهم أننا ما زلنا  الوردة ليست
بأجواء مختلفة يمكننا أن نرقص ويمكننا
أن نكون الوردة ، أعتقد أن هذا
لمجرد أننا سنكون متعبين للغاية
بعد حفلة موسيقية لمدة ساعتين نحاول الرقص
بعد الرقص لا يمكننا الغناء ، فنحن لسنا
في حالة جيدة  كما تعلمون
[موسيقى]
رأيناها وتقريبًا
ستصبحون في الثلاثينيات من العمر ،
نعم ، نعم ،
تقريبًا  وهذا سبب آخر
هو سبب آخر يجعل من الصعب حقًا دمج
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
رائعًا ، أعتقد أن هذا السؤال له
علاقة أكثر بما نحن عليه الآن
لأنك تعلم أننا
سعداء حقًا كما تعلم في  إحساس ونحن
بالفعل في بعض الأحيان ومع هذا
المزيج ، أعتقد أنه في الواقع
يعبر عن موسيقانا أيضًا ، لذلك عندما
نغني موسيقانا عندما نصنع موسيقانا
، أعني أنه يمكننا الغناء بالسعادة والاستعداد
والحزن والسعادة على  في نفس الوقت وأعتقد
أن هذا يجعل موسيقى
Roses حقًا تبدو وكأنها اليوم ،
ونحن منفتحون حقًا على أن
تكون أغانينا مبهجة حقًا وتحب
شيئًا مثيرًا للاهتمام
حقًا أعتقد أننا سنعمل  اذهب للحصول على الكثير من
الموسيقى المضحكة والممتعة والمثيرة في
وقت لاحق والآن أه نحن سعداء حقًا
بموسيقانا مؤخرًا
والألبوم القادم أعتقد أنه سيكون
رائعًا حقًا ، لذا متى سيكون
ذلك  السابع من أكتوبر هو ألبومنا الكامل أه
ري  تاريخ الإيجار ولكن لدينا أغنية واحدة
ستصدر اسمها الطفولة قريبًا جدًا ،
نعم أي شيء تريد
مشاركته معنا أم تعلم أه هذا
الألبوم بأكمله أه نحن نسميه شفاء
وهي رسالتنا الرئيسية عندما نكون جميعًا
بدأنا الموسيقى وشكلنا الفرقة ، كانت
رسالتنا الرئيسية هي أن الموسيقى
تعالج كل شخص نكتب الموسيقى
والغناء والاستماع إليها الموسيقى نفسها التي
شعرنا أنها لغة عالمية
لكل شخص في العالم ، ولهذا السبب
يمكننا القدوم إلى الإمارات العربية المتحدة والغناء معها.
كلمات كورية أو كلمات إنجليزية وأنت تعلم أنه
لا يهم في نهاية اليوم ،
لذا شعرنا أن الموسيقى
يمكن أن توحدنا حقًا وتوحدنا
وهذا هو السبب في أننا نتحدث دائمًا
عن الشفاء بالموسيقى حتى عندما
نغني  حول المشاعر الحزينة
مثل أغنيتنا الأولى التي تسمى آسف ،
نعم إنها أغنية حزينة ولكن هناك
أشخاص يشعرون بالسعادة عندما يستمعون
إليها عندما تكون سعيدًا بالحزن ،
وأنت تعرف ما أعنيه ، لذا فهي كلها
رئيسية  نقي  يشبه وضع الموسيقى تلبية
كل ما تشعر به في ذلك الوقت
ولهذا السبب نسميه دائمًا حزينًا سعيدًا ،
نعم إنه كلاهما يأتي دائمًا عندما تعرف
متى تريد أن تكون حزينًا
وعندما تستمع إلى موسيقى حزينة ربما
أحيانًا  يمكن التغلب عليها وكل
هذا كان مجرد أنك تعرف هذا الألبوم أه
حقًا نحن فقط نجتمع معًا
لتغيير علامتنا التجارية حقًا ولكن السماح للناس
بمعرفة نوايانا الأولى للموسيقى كانت
الفكرة الرئيسية لذلك أطلقنا عليها أنها
تشفيك على إضاعة وقتك
[موسيقى]
أجنبية
أوه أولاً  من بين كل ذلك ، لن أستخدم
النغمات العالية
ولكنك تعرف أغنية Turbo التي كتبناها
عندما كتبت الأغنية مثل نعم
سأستخدم نغمة عالية لأن Sammy
و Leo سيغنيان ويمكنهما الغناء ،
نعم ، يكتبان الألحان بشكل صحيح
ثم يكتبونها ويحضرونها
إلينا وهي مثل هذه النغمات العالية حقًا
ونشعر أن الجو حار جدًا
ويشعرون وكأننا لا نشاهدها ، فلا بأس
أنك تغني هنا
[ضحك]
إنها في  المطر
آدم الشيطان حتى لا يقوم من ذ  أنت
مريض بعد الآن
[موسيقى]
والنغمة العالية هي إصدار Virgin the High
وهي في The Fray
[Music
] ، وأغاني الورد التي تعرفها عالية
جدًا وتعجبني من حيث أن لدي
أغانٍ منفردة مناسبة جدًا عندما أكتب
أغانٍ منفردة  مثل المتوسط ​​ولكن عندما
تحدث أغاني الورد ، فأنت تعلم عندما نقوم
بحفلتنا الموسيقية لهذا السبب لا نحصل أبدًا على
الحفلة حقًا بعد ذلك لأننا جميعًا
متعبون جدًا
بعد عرض واحد انتهينا ، نعم
انتهينا
[موسيقى]
أجنبية
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
بعد قضاء خمسة أعوام من العمر ستة أعوام وسبع سنوات
معًا ، أعتقد أننا نعرف بعضنا
البعض جيدًا الآن وننتهي من
الخدمة العسكرية وجميع الأشياء
التي تحدث ، أعتقد أننا نشعر بحرية حقًا
بشأن ما سنفعله أنت  أعلم
أن هدفي أو ما تريده هو على الأرجح القيام
بالموسيقى
معهم لأن الوردة سعيدة إلى الأبد
أبدًا بعد
هذا هو هدفي في
الواقع ونشعر بالسعادة حقًا
نعم هذا رائع حقًا ،
نعم كما قال ليو ، نحن بالتأكيد
لدينا غرضنا من أجل  عزف الموسيقى بشكل فردي
وأيًا كان هذا الغرض وأيًا كان
هذا الغرض يتغير إلى ، نريد أن نكون
قادرين على القيام بذلك معًا في نهاية
اليوم
ومن خلال موسيقانا نريد أن نكون
قادرين على إنشاء ألبوم أو موسيقى
يمكن أن يربطها الأشخاص  إلى
وأن الأشخاص الذين يمكن أن يكونوا بجانب الناس
مهما مروا بها
حتى مثل الأيام الأكثر سعادة ،
والأيام المحبطة التي تعرفها في بعض
أيام الاكتئاب مثل كل ما نريد القيام به هو أن نكون
قادرين على إنشاء أداة الاستماع هذه ،
شيء يمكن أن يحصل عليه صديق  من
خلال كل ما
يمرون به حتى يكون هذا هو
هدفها الرئيسي من أجل الوردة ، نعم
أه بالنسبة لي ،
نعم ، أريد أن أعزف
الموسيقى وأقوم بالحفلات الموسيقية أو الفرق الموسيقية
مع الأشخاص الذين أحبهم  مثل
أعضائنا أو شركائنا أن كل
معجبينا
لأنني
أعتقد أن أهم شيء هو
الناس الناس الطيبون
بالنسبة لي
أم أن هدفي هو
أه إسعاد العديد من الأشخاص من خلال
موسيقانا
ثم
[الموسيقى]
أم
إذا كنت أفعلها منفردًا ربما
أممممم
أريد أن أظهر
أسلوب الموسيقى الخاص بي ،
نعم ، هذا هو هدفي
، لست متأكدًا من أنني لست متأكدًا ،
حسنًا ، ماذا عن الشخص الذي أعيش فيه
بخلاف الموسيقى والحياة المهنية فقط
كأفراد مثلك تمامًا أو
أعرفه
لكن الموسيقى ليس لدي ما أضيفه هنا
كأفراد ، أعتقد
أننا حقًا أه كل ألبوم صحيح ،
حتى هذا المنعطف هذه المرة ، قمنا
برحلة إلى الصحراء
في La ، انتهينا من الألبوم هناك
وأنت تعلم أن هذا لم يكن  لا يمكننا أن نقول فقط
أن هذا كان مخصصًا للموسيقى فقط كان من المفترض أن نجد
أنفسنا وعندما نجد أخيرًا من
نحن حقًا ونتقبله ،
فأعتقد أنك ستتعلم قبول الآخرين
ومشاركة الحب والقرف وتكون أكثر
ثقة فيك  بشرتك
ستجلب الطاقة الجيدة فقط وأنت تعلم
أننا
نتحدث دائمًا عن هؤلاء كثيرًا
من حيث صحتنا العقلية وأشياء من
هذا القبيل ، وأه كما تعلم أننا ما زلنا
نحاول اكتشاف أنفسنا في
نهاية  اليوم وسيكون ذلك نعم
اعتقدت أنك انتهيت منه ، نعم مثل
w  أحب المغامرة بأشياء جديدة
، تجربة جديدة ، وأعتقد أننا سنعمل
على المغامرة على نحو متقطع قدر
الإمكان ونقرأها
على أغنيتنا أو مثل الأغاني الفردية أو
الواقعية ، ونحن نتطلع حقًا
إلى أنماط مختلفة
عواطف مختلفة في ذلك ، نعم ، هذا رائع جدًا
، أتمنى لكم كل التوفيق يا رفاق ، شكرًا
جزيلاً لكم ، شكراً لكم ، لقد كانت
مقابلة ملهمة للغاية لأكون صادقين ، يا
رفاق تحدثوا ، لذا ما أعتقده ، فماذا
شكراً جزيلاً لكم على وقتكم
اليوم وسنراكم الليلة في الحفلة الموسيقية ،
شكرًا لكم على استضافتنا شكرًا
[موسيقى]